gets the ball today in the first game of
this three-game series
as yandy diaz stands in
diaz the right-handed hitting third
baseman batting 258
354 on base percentage 12 homer 62 rbi
this one is shot back into left field
pretty well tagged that's going to go
home to left by yandi diaz over that
19-foot wall out there
and the rays break out in front
striking quickly
two to nothing
i mean just out that ball is down and
away and he basically one hands it into
the left field seats it plays cozy out
there those crawford boxes and the rays
take full advantage early michael walker
takes them out tonight for the tampa bay
race and one last chance here to show
out you know going into the postseason
trying to finish
the season strong and doing it against a
lineup that's going to be quite a
challenge one out of nobody on for alex
bregman batting 284
368 on base percentage 11 homers 53 runs
bad at him
and he gets the inside edge right there
on that change up
bregman
shaking his head and bregman takes it
and it's maybe just off but certainly
close enough to call one on two out
raised with a two nothing lead and
alvarez one of the two lefties in the
lineup
and he goes up and gets him on the foul
tip strikeout and alvarez may have
expanded the zone a bit and that'll do
it for houston
we got the top of the order to the plate
again who's brandon lau
and that's a base hit just fair
that left side open
and the rays are going to have a couple
men in scoring position here further
evidence that baseball defies even
physics
change up
loud got way out in front you can see it
split the end of the bat but it went
foul and spun back fair now yandy diaz
who had a home run his first time up as
he strikes out diaz to end the inning
big strikeout there for kitty the tucker
comes up 291 of the year 28 homer's 88
knocked in
and there's out on strikes this time i'm
sure that this is not exactly where he
wanted it but he got away with it he has
267 of eight home runs
and straight three call
that pitch down around that corner ryan
wills likes it diaz doesn't he is caught
looking
makes the big pitch right there and
again a good job by zanino
bringing that pitch back up now it's
chaz mccormick's turn
batting 258 313 on base percentage
and a swing and miss on the fastball 97.
michael walker right there against him
striking out the last three batters he
faces on a grand total of nine pitches
astros looking for their first hit
tonight against michael walker jordan
struck out his last time up straight
three called on the outside corner at
the bottom of the zone a change-up took
care of alvarez and waka once he's found
that that's a strike has gone to it
numerous times again might have just
skimmed the very bottom part of the zone
good job but
byzanino to go get it
four and two thirds innings in has not
allowed a hit so far
chopped
down to third gandhi diaz takes care of
that and michael walker has set down 12
in a row still has not allowed a hit
tonight saw the reaction in the raised
dugout giving congrats to michael walker
that means he's out of the game
five innings of no hit baseball may have
gone to the bullpen and andrew kittridge
two-ounce base is empty alex bregman
struck out and lined out
alex first pitch swinging sends one deep
to left center field all the way back
and gone
[Applause]
it's now a two-to-one game thank
goodness for that pitching change huh
right here not wasting any time got a
pitch to handle and went into launch
mode
has walked and popped up has his average
going down to 317 as
they keep an eye on things he's
trying to hold off lad guerrero and a
teammate
there's a ball into right center field
not hit hard but eule finds a perfect
spot with everybody shifted over
yuli guriel a two out base in it that's
just gorgeous too two strikes we
mentioned he lets the ball travel better
than just about anybody let it get deep
see it and just use your hands here is
single to right and fly to deep center
one for two
up the middle correa will have to stop
and plant and he still turns the double
play how do you do it day in and day out
carlos correa a six to three double play
taylor is out of the inning and the
raised lead stays at just one for nobody
3 56 this year as a righty might be his
last opportunity to continue this on bay
streak he is over for three tonight
three and two with two out nobody on two
to one three and two he walked him ball
four franco streak remains alive and
that will extend that streak
to 42 games
one out going on for altuve who's over
threes grounded out three times
altuve drives one deep to left field and
we are tied up
jose altuve ties his career high with 31
home runs and it's a 2-2 game in the
eighth he got a hanging slider and
smashed it 102.7 off the bat estimated
401 feet randy a rosarina tough night
for a rose arena three strikeouts all
swinging
he swings shoots it into right that's
got a chance tucker to the wall gone
home run off the bat of a rosarina
an opposite field blast
and the rays lead three to two
rosarena
gets number 20.
and it gives the range the lead and
carlos correa will come to the plate as
the winning run
and the ground ball great stop but the
flip attempt will not work throw to
first they get the out there
yep astros are challenging is correa's
left foot on the base just before that
ball gets into the back of choi's glove
save
it gets overturned upon review and
correa is on first as the winning run
siri the tying run correa the winning
run oled misty has intentionally walked
chaz mccormick is the hitter facing jt
chagwa
all four were tied up
what a walk by chaz mccormick
he had to earn that one
but castro
will get an opportunity
to be a hero here
ball four game over
magic number down to one
a walk-off walk
from jason castro
and the astros have a chance to pop
champagne later on tonight